my battery's flashing well isn't that
just mother symbolism directly in my
face yeah I see it camera in my back
when you braid dirty air it doesn't
necessarily look clean but the trying
too hard distracts people from it being
so dirty you're welcome
welcome to my favorites video usually
people do these videos at the end of the
month tell you the things that they like
in the month that we all just existed in
and I say why why look at die tomorrow
so why not know what I like today so
maybe I instead of calling your
favorites I was thinking about this name
you're called my frequently used scrap
my sucks so let's look at some huh
and there go all of my brand deals first
yeah he's yeah he's yeah you say that
every million beauty gurus on YouTube
that have already talked about this and
I bought it because they said it out
loud and I wondered if they were foolish
and no they're just full of [ __ ] this is
benefits hoola bronzer and like it goes
like this
compute well no it's not the best
packaging it's cute but it's not I don't
know there's something other packaging I
don't love and there's something about
myself I don't love because now I've
become a person that complains about
makeup packaging anyway this bronzer is
really great it goes on well the color
looks decent and I don't have any sort
of allergic reaction to it a lot of
writers I find street grant they go on
like you can see the brushstrokes I have
this on my face right now I'm not
actually this tan I just try a lot next
Mac yeah you say kiss yeah this is
L'Oreal Paris infallible Pro matte
foundation
that's the funny thing about makeup they
love their goddamn adjectives for
everything I thought this foundation
because Megan rings who is a beauty ish
guru ish person on YouTube talked about
it and she's got really beautiful skin
and a really great foundation routine
and so I tried it and I really liked it
it's cheap it goes on my face and it's
full of sexual innuendos that was me
fapping for you no clapping nothing okay
I did not find my correct shade all over
- eh that's a little bit too dark for me
but I've mixed it with another shade
that works really well this is super
matte and I have it on my face now if
you can stand under Hulk the insecurity
if you have oily skin I assume that this
would be great for you because this
literally like a bat goes on your face
and just looks Matt I'm not shining
bright like any diamonds I'm staying
very matte like
that like that next these kicks a a
Cusack
Katie these are some laura mercier lip
glosses or they call it lip glass I got
the middle of a kit off the lot look
calm these are tiny little travel lip
glosses and oh look at the colors yeah
and they're called pink spark at first I
thought it's a pink Spanx and there's
gonna be like okay Laura I see what
you're doing do i I don't know azalea
eggie bond on Ricky Martin
thank you mama and papi because that
makes sense
um can't do it oh my god
I used to love you guys I was gonna
speak so highly of you but now you're
not being cheap [ __ ] just beep I like
these because the colors are really cute
it goes on really smooth not too sticky
on the lips that's what she said me he
said it as a not gross thing and they
travel really well because they're so
tiny me yeah that's ok sayuki's yeah can
you say this is Cheryl its shampoo
blonde and silver I was recommended this
by spike and Tyler Oakley both people
who have blonde hair and maintain it
very well and I also have blond hair
they're not maintaining it very well
right now because well guess who laying
us out from commercial break the roots
but this is really cheap like drugstore
shampoo it's purple shampoo which is
really good for maintaining blonde hair
and I bought it off of Amazon because of
leaving my house being not a thing I
enjoy and it works really really well
shimmer lights next babies you see how
cusack
can't you see it they burst and those
that I also got on the pot look calm om
say with many a great thing and they're
from a company called buco these kind of
sandals are really popular
I also accidentally bought 2 pairs of
these the Steve Madden
sandals that I really also like very
very much if that were really cute and
then I got these which are more of a
platform so they give me some elevations
even though I don't need it it just
makes my day more dangerous and more
opportunity for me to fall down wearing
these than wearing these
I love taking chances next thing you say
ass yeah Casey
they are backwards these are overalls
look there's the best part that I got
from Topshop calm but these are super
super comfortable and I've been wearing
these for traveling it confuses people
about my level of sophistication
confuses people though my age and it
confuses people on where I might be from
when people in America are confused by
the way someone dresses they
automatically think that they're
European and then they assume maybe they
don't speak English they don't talk to
them but just like my favorite thing
also I have more pair of overalls any
one of the more recent episodes of the
grace Helbig show means speaking up next
favorite do you see it can you see if
you see it's a television show it's my
top and show the grace Helbig show on E
we've recently moved to Sunday nights at
11 p.m. this is a good thing just so you
guys know it's very very good and I'm
super excited by it the next episode
will be Sunday May 31st at 11 p.m. we're
taking a couple weeks off for a second
and then we'll be back Sunday May 31st
11 p.m. with Adam Devine and Jack Black
so overall neither just saw pitch
perfect and now you did
once it's great Adam Devine is on the
grace Helbig show May 31st 11:00 p.m.
what else do I like Amazon Prime now I'm
just reaching grace you're just reaching
just be done those are my four right now
hope that you guys enjoyed this video if
you did give it a thumbs up subscribe so
that you can come hang out with me
regularly and usually an episode of not
too deep is on today but we also took a
week off do not fear those of you that
weren't afraid to begin with we will be
back with more so it's not too deep next
week no filter tickets are down below
and I've just plug so many things
oh that's also what I'm into extension
cords with a variety of plugs that's it
yep I don't know next you can't see it
you can't see it you can't see this it's
the no filter show tour that had a heart
murmur heart and I are about to embark
on an honor memory arts book you
preorder her book at white a book calm
and click the link below to get tickets
to the shows they're selling up very
quickly
Chicago is our first show so I'm looking
at you Chicago buy some tickets it's
gonna be stupid fun and usually our
first shows are kind of the best ones
because we don't know what we're doing
so we're trying to figure it out so it's
usually kind of a cluster and we've all
learned here but I love folks well
that's now a sentence I've said